Dark Phoenix was directed by Simon
Kinberg longtime writer producer of many
x-men films first-time director and this
film is about Jean Grey and it explores
the devastating power within her and her
difficulties in harnessing it all of the
people in her life like her parents
Charles Xavier and her friends in the
x-men who are trying to save her from
that power as well as some dangerous new
people who would like to harness that
power for themselves it's not the first
time we've explored this aspect of Jean
Grey in a movie x-men The Last Stand did
as well and it was definitely one of the
lesser x-men films well not quite as
terrible as some people say I mean I
much prefer x-men 3 over something like
origins but in the case of Dark Phoenix
I was really looking forward to seeing
these characters with these actors get
involved with this storyline and I
really wanted to see what sophie Turner
was going to do with it
and a major plus of the movie is sophie
turner as this character she's great she
goes through a lot of changing emotions
very quickly and it never seems messy
because of her delivery she's able to
ride the wave that is this character
it's also kind of impossible for James
McAvoy to be bad in a movie he's just
amazing and everything and once again
he's terrific as Charles Xavier so is
Michael Fassbender as magneto there's a
lot of great talent in this movie and
it's rarely wasted unfortunately I would
say the acting is my favorite aspect of
this movie beyond that this was a messy
and dull film that didn't really do much
for me and this is coming from someone
who has heavily defended Fox's x-men
films I really love this franchise and I
have for nearly 20 years I like almost
all of them but in the case of Dark
Phoenix I wouldn't say the film made me
angry or anything I didn't leave the
theater upset it was just very bland and
it feels like we built to this and
nothing really happens of interest
because they approach this character as
this new threat that could completely
dismantle the world that Charles Xavier
has tried to build and it's this major
threat that Jean Grey has these
abilities that she could dish
Troi all of that and yes she does do
some bad things and yes she does anger
some characters because of choices that
she makes but it's never like the kind
of thing you would expect to completely
dismantle the government's view of
mutants but with previous x-men movies
even the ones that are still within the
timeline that hasn't been erased which
we'll talk about in a second those films
featured mutants doing things that were
far worse than anything Jean Grey does
in this movie that apparently threatens
to dismantle everything Xavier has built
I was expecting it to be a lot darker
especially for the title I honestly I
knew it wasn't gonna happen but I wish
this movie was rated R I think it really
could have benefited from that and I
don't think it would have lost an
audience at all after films like Logan
and Deadpool one and two within this
franchise were so successful I think
this movie really could have benefited
from some more intensity but let's talk
about that timeline for a second because
it is actually really confusing now and
it's starting to bother me I've begun to
pay attention to it a lot more in the
past with the x-men movies I just tried
to watch each one and see like what that
film did for me and its contained story
but when Days of Future past came out it
was a great movie but it kind of screwed
things up now the universe is all over
the place things that maybe happened or
that we thought happened haven't
happened quite in that way entire films
have been erased and we're not supposed
to take the events of those films
seriously anymore because in Dark
Phoenix things happen that just don't
relate to the pre-existing films we've
seen x-men 1 and 2 and so obviously
things have now been scattered something
alternate is happening something has
been changed by whatever Logan did in
Days of Future past because if you go
into this film expecting some sort of
connective tissue from 1992 when this
film takes place to the year 2000 when
x-men happened you're not gonna get that
for one apparently in eight years James
McAvoy goes from looking like James
McAvoy to looking like
Patrick Stewart and if you really want
to examine the narrative of the x-men
franchise especially with Dark Phoenix
it starts to get really annoying and it
threatens to ruin the entire film and so
I tried not to think about it while I
was watching the
and just roll with the punches but if
you care that's really gonna bother you
I think you can tell there was an effort
to back off from the more stylized
approach of previous x-men films because
the way Kinberg directs which by the way
this is his feature directorial debut
his only other credit was the most
recent season finale of The Twilight
Zone Jordan peels reboot so this is a
huge thing to just suddenly direct and
you can tell you can tell that he has
not handled action set-pieces you can
tell that he doesn't always know how to
make a conversation feel like something
other than shot reverse shot over and
over again because sometimes the scenes
in which characters are just sitting
down talking can be kind of boring and
since this is written and directed by
Ken Berg this is absolutely his vision
on screen that being said the film
underwent extreme reshoots from what I
understand to add a third act sequence
involving a train now I didn't actually
know that until after the movie I did
some research about it and so watching
the movie I was just like okay this must
be what he wants to do and I remember
when it got to that train sequence I was
like wow this is like way more exciting
than the rest of the movie why is this
like suddenly a different movie I even
said in my head while watching it this
seems like a different movie and then I
went home and found out it was a reshoot
and this is disappointing for a lot of
reasons people love the Jean Grey
Phoenix stuff I do and this is the
second time where they've tried to do it
in a film and it just didn't really work
and it has very little to do with the
themes of that story the idea of Jean
Grey struggling with this power within
her whether or not she can embrace it
can she still keep her friends if she
embraces this power or if she does is
she just gonna go full-blown evil and
murder the entire universe I love the
idea of exploring that but both of these
films have done the exact same thing
with this character when she is in that
state they just make her like a ticking
time bomb which is boring that works in
a few scenes but then after that you
have to explore the complexities of this
a little more and just having her be a
ticking time bomb it just reduces it it
makes it less than what it could be
Jessica Chastain has a major
contribution to this film that I did not
know about and I don't know if other
people know about it so
I'm not going to get into it because I
didn't watch too many of the trailers I
saw like one and I didn't read any of
the articles or interviews that always
come out about these characters and what
they're doing but her character has a
lot of screen time and her goals are a
major part of this story and you can
tell it's trying to be something that is
like an influence on Jeanne but nothing
is really coming of it it was horribly
handled and really throwaway almost
disposable and yet it's so important to
the narrative but it doesn't feel like
it is you can just tell that the writing
really needs it to be important but you
just don't care about her entire story
in how she relates to Jean Grae also
side point Cyclops has a line in this
movie that I will never forget because
my friend and I laughed about it on the
way home for probably five straight
minutes
it's him trying to be super hard and it
just didn't work so in the end the best
parts of Dark Phoenix for me were the
actors everyone's great in the movie but
it just didn't feel like it had the
intensity this story needed and it's
messages well very important felt forced
and not earned character actions are
very important but instead they just
sort of speak what the writer is hoping
the themes are instead of actually doing
and showing these things and while that
train sequence added a lot of action to
the film and made the finale more
exciting than it had been it was
unfortunately a case of too little too
late the rest of the movie before that
wasn't remotely as entertaining and the
characters say and do things that just
don't lead to anything this should have
been so much better than it was and it
could have been if they just went for
that are and really let Jean Grae loose
but they don't it's almost like they
played it safe with her
I'm gonna give Dark Phoenix a C so guys
if you do see Dark Phoenix I'd like to
know what you think because this is sort
of an end of an era
now that Marvel has Fox 19 years and I
mean the New Mutants is still coming out
apparently even though it's been like in
post forever and changes in another
x-men movie with reshoots I am excited
to see that though I want to see what
they do with that film but nevertheless
if you guys do see Dark Phoenix let me
know what you think I
I want to give a big thank you to the
sponsor for this video and that is honey
if you've ever bought something online
but then discovered you could have
gotten it for cheaper that's a very
frustrating experience but with honey a
free browser extension it scans the
internet for coupon codes and other
discounts and then like magic it
automatically applies them to your cart
at checkout it knows about every coupon
code sale or discounted over 37,000
sites like Amazon Walmart Best Buy
Nordstrom and more I buy a lot of stuff
from Best Buy and Game Stop I was
literally just at Best Buy today
blu-rays video games all kinds of stuff
honey is an easy and free way to save
money at those stores online it's also
incredibly easy to install it took me
two clicks over 10 million people are
already saving with honey they have over
100,000 five-star reviews on the google
chrome store and Time magazine called
them basically free money
look there really is no reason not to
try out this service if you shop online
as often as I do it can save you a lot
of money so please do check out join
honey calm slash Tuchman in the
description below that's join honey calm
slash stuckman thank you so much to them
for sponsoring this video and thank you
guys for watching as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]